[Music]
hey you guys yeah
yeah
did he get back to about four last night
i did not realize that well it was the
last memento at least the last memento
mori at eyebar slash barbarella so it
was a little emotional
they wanted to take a picture of
everybody so everybody had to get like
on the dance floor like when they turned
all the lights on and they turned
although i think you went out to the bar
you were the only person that wasn't in
the face
and uh well i didn't realize because we
were having such a good time and we were
drinking so much and i was talking to
people and stuff like that that i didn't
realize that it was like closing and the
lights came on i'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on and i'm like oh it's like 3 30
in the morning whoops demetri and jen's
daughter [ __ ] went out for the first
time she's 18 she was all gothed out
with her [ __ ] face piercing things in
her dimple cheeks and [ __ ] and she was
cute as [ __ ] and [ __ ] hooked her up
with [ __ ] nick
[Laughter]
nick's like yeah man he got real shy
he's like yeah man she's pretty cute
yeah yeah
and then like his mom here [ __ ] her
mom was
jen was like oh she likes him yeah
i hope that works out i don't
i don't want demetri and jen getting mad
at me if like if
they break up well he's 21 you know
she's better off with a guy who's 21
than an 18 year old those dudes are
[ __ ] dorks okay that's true don't get
her into more trouble than a guy who's
actually [ __ ] working for a living
yeah i mean yeah he does he works in a
print shop right here works and prints
out got a car and he's got getting cool
clothes and [ __ ]
he still lives at home so he's not
[ __ ] struggling or anything you know
he's a nice dude i like yeah yeah
uh i think aleya was there last night
too although i just saw her i i think
aleah was there too late i didn't see
alia um
i thought i saw her she didn't say hi
but it was like really crowded it was
not even
it was really crowded
so uh so yeah so we're a little bit
tired so forgive us if we kind of space
out um
for a little bit but i said we did want
to come on briefly and like talk about
this movie because
this was another one that we were just
kind of scrolling through like on amazon
prime and it was in the free to me
section yeah and uh and i was like how
can you not want to watch it with a
title like the torture chamber of dr
sadism yeah plus christopher lee is in
it yeah he's not like the main he's kind
of in it at the beginning and then at
the end so he's not like the main i mean
he's the main attraction obviously but
yeah he's the bad guy uh but he's not in
it for like the whole middle of the
thing so this is a german film and this
came out in 1967.
if you look it up on wikipedia it's
actually its original title was the
blood demon which that kind of makes
sense
um also it because because we said it's
probably one of those but because i
think even when the movie comes on like
on amazon prime i can't remember what
title comes up but it wasn't
uh the title that they have on the card
it wasn't uh towards the chamber of
doctors save them eyes camera what it
was but there it goes by a couple other
titles one was the snake pit and the
pendulum because it does have a bit
that's sort of like based on pitt and
the pendulum that garland post story
they're just trying to shoot hordes of
[ __ ] and castle of the walking dead yeah
which uh that's that's kind of accurate
also
kind of accurate there are some strong
points of this movie it looks pretty
good i think i don't think this is a
great copy it does need to be restored
but i can tell that when the movie was
new and you saw it on the screen it
probably was pretty cool to watch it's
got cute girls in it a lot of nudity and
they're just like these cute german
vampire type girls
goth girls 60s goth girls
and a lot of gore
and and a pretty good idea
it's about
this you find your first scene you find
out they had this rich nobleman he was
put to death they put this damn mask on
his face it had spikes on it they
dragged sunday disaster yeah and then
they [ __ ] tore them apart with horses
and it was because he had killed
12 12 virgins 12 virgins in
horrendous ways that even they would
couldn't even forgive a noble he could
never repay his for his crimes he's
trying to be immortal you you got to
break a few eggs you don't know that
until later
he what he was doing is he was torturing
women to try to extract their damn
souls like their their uh
their fight
the more they had he tried to get them
to fight for as much as life as they
possibly could so they'd be scared
because it made their souls right more
potent yeah he's extracting her their
life energy you know and he was going to
make this into an elixir
and it turned out he needed 13 of them
and they killed him on [ __ ]
girl 12. yeah but he had his whole plot
to where he had some servants who
partially were
like had some life extension he could
give them slight life extension and then
they were gonna let time pass and then
finally they were gonna resurrect him on
a certain day where they could do that
very last one and he'd become immortal
and he and so it's a trip you know what
i mean he's all still cutting the pieces
they got to reassemble him
and it's christopher lee when he comes
up all right
well he's christopher lee at the
beginning too yeah yeah yeah but then
because you know but then they put him
back together he's like tada he's crazy
yeah right uh it's got a lot of it's
it's not a comedy
but it's humorous because
one of the characters this like a [ __ ]
vampire goth [ __ ]
countess
who likes to
seduce priests and you know she's
and all the priests are these choppy
they're not they're they're they're the
seminary students really aren't they
they're not really full-blown priests
yeah they're like act they're they're
what they call them acolytes or
something yeah what is there some kind
of religious school right next to her
castle where she's drinking them up
and uh she's going out to the window and
going yeah
yeah yeah
i don't know if that's a german actress
but she's little she's probably well the
one that
one or five two and cute because i had
kind of forgotten about that because
what happened to the beginning like when
christopher lee gets drawn and quartered
um because he killed 12 virgins then
they jump ahead 35 years 35 years yeah i
think uh so there's a whole thing too
with like this one countess
in the middle part of the film which is
35 years later
being like the reincarnate or the
daughter she's a daughter right it's the
of the [ __ ] countess
did i get that right granddaughter oh
it's granddaughter i believe i thought
it was daughter but i could be
remembered i thought it was
granddaughter it doesn't really matter
it is the same actress i believe and you
said she because i said man she looks
just like barbara steele yeah um and you
said yes she looks familiar her name is
karen door and she was actually in
uh you only live twice
the bond movie oh okay and she was also
in an alfred hitchcock movie called
topaz okay uh so you might have seen she
looked familiar yeah like i thought that
too but then i was thinking well is it
just because she's like a dead ringer
for barbara steele she looks almost
exactly like this deal
um oh i wanted to mention to you you'll
find this amusing the guy that directed
this he mostly did like german films
obviously he did a [ __ ] ton of them but
he also
directed that documentary chariots of
the gods okay yeah that didn't that's a
piece of [ __ ] you know what's more
shocking about that is that that
documentary was nominated for an oscar
yeah well it was ahead of its time i'm
like was there what was the competition
that it was ahead of this time it was
like great planet earth probably yeah
that one was another one was terrible
those um
those documentaries when i was a little
kid man they impressed a lot of people
that's true people just believed them
and they're oh yeah scientists believe
scientists know that there's aliens you
know coming down in the past
and if you watch those documentaries it
doesn't even say anything little close
to that
it's very creatively edited very much
kind of like the
the ufos actually ancient alien dudes
with the hair yeah you know
everything is couched you know it has
been said that
by someone we're not saying who but some
people believe somewhere said it yeah
some people believe
experts agree
wait a minute what
some expert they have agreed that
aliens came thousands of years ago you
know and the toltecs were talking to the
aliens you know
really of course everybody knows that
yeah
uh well yeah so so yeah so you have this
kind of prologue at the beginning like i
said where christopher lee who's his cat
his um character name is count regula
yeah he's regulated he's ready he's
regulating the [ __ ] yeah yeah count
regular and um like i said what they
like we can't call him dracula you're
right he's regular he's okay he's the
regular accountant yeah he's his
knockoff count yeah
and they can't call him count chocula
because that would just be silly they
didn't have the [ __ ] license so yeah
so uh so yeah so he gets drawn and
quartered and then over the ensuing
decades like the ensuing 35 years i
think it's i think the wikipedia page
says 40 years but i'm pretty sure it was
35 years
so over the ensuing decades the
townspeople like this rumor has sprung
up that the they call it the blood
castle like where regular lived
i don't know
i mean it there's kind of like a thing
where they think that he's still alive
or something or there there's like some
kind of thing about it there's a lot of
superstition about the death yeah
there's like it's haunted or some [ __ ]
like that so then by the damn dragon by
the vampire girl yeah and then so then
you get uh for different reasons you
have like a couple of people going up
there like there's this guy
um this is in the 18th century by the
way
they don't really say where it is
there's this guy named old in time in
olden times it says in olden times old
and t-y
you know that time in history but um
yeah and it's in germany somewhere it's
in bavaria or something uh so there's
this lawyer uh at the beginning his
name's roger
and he was actually in uh the rko tarzan
movies like back in the early 50s uh
among other things he's also german i'm
pretty sure but um
yeah so he gets
somebody writes him a letter
uh because he's like an orphan or
something and like he doesn't know what
his identity is so somebody writes him a
letter and said hey you need to come up
to this castle and see count regular and
he'll like clue you in about your
identity or whatever so he's on his way
up there and then you have this baroness
uh lillian von brabant and her little uh
you know her lady in waiting or whatever
whose name is babette
and they're on their way up there
because she supposedly is gonna get some
inheritance yeah so
they go and then they kind of run into
the comic relief who is
a monk
except not he's pretending to be a monk
hold on let me back up
let me put this picture in the minds of
these men
so this what was certain name again the
the the uh the baroness the baroness
what was her name lillian von brabant
yeah okay so lillian
is a little short cute burnett she's
probably i don't know i think she's
probably supposed to be about 24 25.
but bet is her [ __ ] friend
who's uh kind of like the dramatic
[ __ ]
blonde
you know lots of brilliant lots of
braids and boobs and [ __ ] you know
they're they're both they're both brains
they're both smoking and
it looks like porn is going to break out
at any moment it kind of does it's not
really there's a lot of nudity in it and
they knew how to sell movies back then
it was a young male audience and they're
trying to give them some [ __ ] to gaze at
and uh it succeeded succeeded um
the sets are good too in this i have to
say i really really like the production
design on this like the art design
particularly that one scene and i think
you even mentioned this when it was
going on the one scene where they're
going it gets dark and they're going in
the coach yeah up toward the castle and
it's you know it's like i said it's
night time yeah and the and the guy
that's like driving the coach is like i
don't want to do this it's like because
there's all these superstitions about it
and then he starts seeing all these like
bodies and like body parts like trees
hanging from the trees and like coming
out of the trees yeah it looks really
cool and it's i really really like the
way they lit it yeah and it's all 3d
yeah
the carriage is going through this
forest it's lit up and they're showing
the angles right and it's kind of like
if you've ever been to the haunted
mansion and or the haunted mansion in in
disneyland's kind of reminded me of that
when you're going through the deal yeah
we're going through the you're going
outside the cemetery kind of like that
kind of like that like not not as like
not as over the top over the top is that
similar lighting similar structure yeah
it really was outside it was creepy yes
creepy uh you can tell that this this
copy of it is not
totally restored but it it probably
looked really cool when it came out a
lot of giallo type of lighting it's not
a cheap movie it was a well-made movie
yeah you know this isn't like a [ __ ]
movie you know somebody pulled out of
their ass for a couple grand yes
this is a german production it's trying
it's it's
it's trying to compete with hammer yeah
this was yeah this was 1967 so i'm
trying to think of like some of the
other the hammer movies that came out
they just this is definitely trying to
like compete with hammer like i said
christopher lee of being in it yeah so
you got stars in it and you got
good-looking girls and [ __ ] good sets
and
i remember i wasn't pissed off by the
score or anything there wasn't anything
in the score that bothered me there was
gore in it
and uh comedic relief
you know what i mean there's comedy in
it too
mostly the mostly the fake monk guys
yeah and it's all sexual comedy
pretty much worried about sticking his
balls and seeing dicks and balls where
he's looking at
sex and everything just you know just
showing like religious paranoia where
the priests are always afraid that
they're seeing sex
oh my god until that damn hot ass
vampire girl [ __ ] get out on him and
then he's like oh well okay she drank
his ass though
she drank his ass yeah well yeah so uh
so mostly like once the
little ragtag group gets up to blood
castle
then they're kind of forced to contend
with this servant named anatol
who you find out later was like the
servant of christopher lee's character
count regular yeah fourth throw down
said there's count regular baroness
semi-regular yeah and the vi count
intermittently intermittently
yeah
the movie knows that it's pulling these
tricks on you too it's not trying to
hide the fact that it's trying to get
around [ __ ] it's good it's good i mean
the writing is good i mean well the most
of the middle part of the movie is uh
you know the gang being sort of like
chased by anatole
and uh falling into various traps like i
said you know the uh the lawyer guy like
roger he gets trapped in a pit in the
pendulum situation
like in the and then um
the baroness like falls into a snake pit
at some point or almost falls into a
snake pit because they're trying to like
make her scared so anatole you find out
that that almost falls into some spikes
yeah that's right
and [ __ ] yeah and she was like tied up
to them going oh no they're like lower
ground like a spiky thing and uh so
there's that
and yeah so there so most of the middle
part of the movie is them just going
around this castle like falling into
various traps and getting pursued by
anatol
and uh you find out so anatol he had
drank
some of the elixir because it wasn't
finished because the whole rule was he
had to kill 13 versions and he got
killed before he
did the 13th one so he's like wanting to
do the 13th one like for immortality
and
so he i guess he figured it out that
anatole
uh
drank some of the elixir that he made so
he like could live longer
although he died and then came back
because he said he was like walking dead
right yeah and his blood was green yeah
and at first i was like what and then i
was like oh well because the elixir was
green yeah he he wasn't really the
walking dead again yeah i guess he was
life extension he was a life expert well
he said that he died though that's right
he got home yeah you got him but he
didn't kill him yeah right and he like
came back so his whole thing so they so
they had made those yeah he they made
this whole plan where christopher lee
was like well you know if i get killed
like before my mission is completed then
you need to you know bring me back so
that's what he does he like has him he
has him in this like uh glass coffin
thing with his little arms and legs and
and [ __ ] like not attached so you know
when when they get the baroness up there
who is supposed to be the 13th one
because she's the daughter or
granddaughter or whoever of
the original baroness
and so for extra potency they're gonna
get her as the 13th one yeah so like i
said so christopher lee is in it at the
beginning
and at the end but mostly in the middle
it's anatole like the servant like
chasing the guy like looking all creepy
like chasing them around and stuff but
like i said i really really liked the
sets on this like the inside of the
castle it looks really cool and i really
like the um they had like those big
murals that were like hieronymus bosch
type stuff like they weren't exactly
that but i'm obviously inspired by that
and they were kind of like
um
i don't know not day glow but they were
like really bright like saturated colors
and with these big murals like on the
walls and that looked really cool i
liked that a lot some of the paintings
they showed were photographs they were
just telling you they were paintings
though
remember that well yeah that's true i
showed the photograph of the [ __ ]
vampire princess girl with [ __ ] nude
[ __ ] booty sticks that's right and
i'm looking at and going like there's no
painting yeah that's a photograph i mean
they at least could have taken the
photograph and like painted over maybe
maybe they didn't have time i didn't
have time i guess i mean maybe that's
easy to do but i did yeah but i mean i
did like that they did like the bashi
and uh sort of murals on the walls those
were really cool it was cool it looked
like a haunted house inside there which
is that was the tone of the of the 60s
that's what they wanted and and a lot of
it looked real
and some of the some of the
bavarian towns they were in were real
medieval towns i don't know where that
was
i'm pretty i mean they yeah they did
shoot it look good look real good thank
you victor
i missed y'all i've been working every
wednesday and friday i'm sorry thank you
man thank you very much
um yeah oracle's talking about uh
christopher lee yeah he elevates
whatever he's in yeah and they have him
kind of looking
a
little a little sallow in this one
because he's just kind of like you know
they made him much paler yeah and you
know and they kind of did his hair where
it's like black and it's kind of we
ought to do a show on christopher lee
cuz he's got a [ __ ] interesting
backstory he did a bunch of hardcore
[ __ ] in his [ __ ] life ian fleming
actually when he was writing
double-oh-seven he was imagining james
bond as christopher lee he evidently
knew him
honestly i would have loved that i think
christopher lee would have made a good
james yeah you know i don't know all the
details i would do the research but he
did a lot of really cool because he's so
[ __ ] suave yeah he was a badass too
we should do
actually you know what one of these days
oh um give me give me a pen please so i
can write it down because otherwise i'll
forget yeah or actually i probably need
paper too now that you're thinking about
it i'm not gonna write it on my hand
it's kind of stuck
um we should do a show that's like
christopher lee and peter cushing okay
yeah that would be cool i'll put it in
the poll and then we'll see
uh cause yeah that would be good
because tomorrow night the show we're
gonna do tomorrow night is
uh sid vicious yeah okay and nancy
sponge
uh so i've already watched like two or
three documentaries about that and like
read all about it like you know because
i wanted to
kind of get
caught back up on it because i hadn't
read about it in such a long time but
that's what we're gonna do the show
about tomorrow night but yeah this is um
this is like a pretty decent like if you
like hammer movies and you want to see
kind of a german take on it
uh as i said i think my favorite thing
about this other than christopher lee
cause i mean obviously he's awesome but
i really really like the sets like i re
and i really like the way they did the
lighting
and like you said that one particular uh
sequence where they're going through the
woods with all the bodies like hanging
from the trees and stuff i really like
the way they lit that it's like really
spooky and like you said it's kind of
like going through the disney world like
the haunted mansion
uh like going through the cemetery not
as goofy as that but
you know it's creepier but i really like
the way they uh they shot it uh yeah
adriana says christopher lee was quite
hot magnetic and charismatic yeah
um he's around for a long time too
people really don't realize that he made
it into the star wars prequel
that's right damn it the [ __ ] ghosts
are called
yeah he was count dooku that's right he
was one of the best things about the
prequels
was count dooku yeah
fourth drawdown says have you ever
reviewed the devil rides out i've been
wanting to because i just rewatched it
probably like a few months ago and i'm
like damn this is like this is a good
movie we should probably put this on the
list but yeah we'll get around to it
because i actually uh really do like
that movie a lot
uh victor was saying what's tomorrow's
show about um yeah i don't know for you
just i'm doing uh we're doing sid
vicious and nancy sponging nancy sid and
nancy yeah that's what we're doing
interesting story it is and it's sad
actually it's it's a really sad uh story
but you know since both of us kind of
grew up in
you know
the kind of punk rock uh milieu i guess
so
yeah most post punk um you know it's so
we can kind of add some [ __ ] about it
yeah as well i mean i was pretty young
when sid vicious died
it was a creation of the old media if
something like that were to happen today
you'd never hear about it that's the
weird thing about it just that they were
famous in their day because it was a lot
harder to be famous back then
uh yeah air time was [ __ ] precious
and that was just some of the few some
of the weird people that made it
into air coverage and then what happened
to them
yeah
and it's still [ __ ] man i still when i
was you know writing the notes and stuff
for the for the episode um you know
people still dress up as sid and nancy
for halloween
so yeah so people still remember him
like this many years later yeah um i did
like that movie did you see the alex cox
movie with uh gary oldman yeah it's a
good movie yeah i actually haven't seen
it in a long time
but some people cast dispersions on them
but uh they were people of their time
yeah they didn't know any better they
came from nothing
yeah sid was an idiot
he was an idiot okay he was by all
accounts um he was very young and had no
idea what was going on he was born
addicted to heroin and he was just an
idiot but he wasn't a
meat a bad person in terms of like
mean-spirited it's just everything was
against the guy
from day one yeah
but well yeah i felt kind of bad for him
i mean he did do some [ __ ] up [ __ ] i'm
not saying that and he was funny he did
do some [ __ ] that was funny he he
it was just
he was built dealt an extremely bad hand
i mean his parents were [ __ ]
[ __ ] heroin addicts
and when he was born addicted to it so
come on
yeah you're doomed well and honestly
nancy didn't have much of a good
upbringing either so there was there was
that whole thing yeah she didn't really
have a chance either to be honest with
you right um let's see do to do camp guy
says i've read all the fleming bond
books they're amazingly good reads i
don't you know what i think that's a
single one i think i read
casino royale yeah
or i've read one of them i know but i
should probably remedy that because
that's probably something and i've only
seen a few of the of the old james bond
yeah
i think i've seen all of them over in
like over the years yeah because they
seemed like they were on cable all the
time yeah and i was just kind of like oh
jake fine okay i liked the craig ones
um
i i remember really liking the timothy
dalton once but i haven't seen him in so
long i saw those in the theater when
they came out and at the time i [ __ ]
loved them i wouldn't mind going back to
re seeing them again yeah and then i
really liked golden eye i thought
goldeneye was really good
uh but then like what was that guy that
what was the guy who was what was his
name guy who did uh golden eye
what was that actor's name
pierce brosnan pierce brosnan yeah
um i noticed that the pierce brosnan
one's kind of progressively kind of got
sillier
there was always kind of a campiness to
to to james bond but yeah they just kind
of got a little
some people talk bad about
the craig once i liked all the craig
ones
and some of the ones that people didn't
like i liked them the most like i liked
casino royale everybody liked that one
but i liked quantum masalas i thought
that was one of the second best ones
uh i liked spectre uh the new one that
came out
it was kind of [ __ ] doing some shout
outs to even to the entire bond series
and did some stuff that was a little bit
out of character for
for the craig series but i still loved
it still liked it
and people oh well they had you know
everybody got killed man that was the
last one he was going to be in you had
to give a [ __ ] ending to every one of
those characters including felix
and felix died and sort of bond
but they weren't coming back anyway
those actors weren't coming back you
have to reboot it now yeah that's what
they're going to do just like that and
they're pissing me off because everybody
knows the [ __ ] what's his name should
be james bond but they they said they
won't give it to him
danny rowling says uh christopher lee
was a pilot dog fighter would you badass
yeah uh and then oracle says he couldn't
stay a pilot though he had a weird
vision failure that watched him out of
pilot duty uh it was a real shame
because he was a natural pilot victor
asked have you all reviewed the new
texas chainsaw massacre on netflix i've
had a lot of people ask me about it and
it really seems like
i don't you know i'll reserve judgment
until i see it myself but every horror
channel that i subscribe to like just
from looking at the thumbnails on their
reviews of it i'm thinking that it's
probably not all that good
but uh i don't know we'll see oracle
also said on the other hand christopher
lee went into raf intelligence and
hunted down nazis which is also badass
um
yeah amanda says uh that texas chainsaw
massacre film on netflix is very
disappointing that's kind of what i
heard um i'm you know it looks like
people aren't saying it's the worst
thing ever but they're just saying like
you know why
but you know uh yeah fourth renown said
sid vicious was still an idol to a lot
of young women when i was at college in
the 1990s yeah i kind of feel like even
nowadays even though it was such a long
time ago like he's still kind of a
cultural icon oh man that's [ __ ] that
[ __ ] never down took a shower
and was [ __ ] constantly picking his
nose and [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah well i mean that was kind of the
whole the whole punk thing
at least they're all covered with zits
and
yeah [ __ ] like that and it's like it's
it seemed like every [ __ ] picture
that you ever see of uh syd and john
lyden as well like they always had these
big [ __ ] zits that they didn't
scratching all over their face
well i guess you can get away with that
when you're 16 or 17 you know what i
mean the girls are full still think
you're [ __ ] cute because you're only
16 or 17 but imagine that [ __ ]
at 40. yeah
never showering and [ __ ] dirty
picking his nose and eating the boogers
and [ __ ] on tv
my friends were dirty man yeah they were
yeah
you know very working class that's just
kind of so working-class people were
dirty no i'm just saying that they you
know
they were i think they they were working
class they didn't have [ __ ] jobs they
were like underclass i was talking about
like their parents obviously but like i
said yeah we'll get into that like uh
tomorrow night but yeah so uh yeah so
let's circle back to the christopher lee
movie as i said if you like hammer
movies and you want to see a german take
on it this is on amazon prime
for so you can watch for free i'm pretty
sure it's also on 2b um you know so if
you don't have amazon prime i think you
can watch it on there as well might be
under a different title uh because it
has like four different ones
um
if you look it up on wikipedia it
actually is called the blood demon but
it's the same movie uh torture chamber
of doctor sadism uh obviously that's the
best title but it does have some other
ones as well so uh yeah so i guess we'll
wrap it up i gotta take a nap and
[Laughter]
[ __ ] like that because i'm still kind of
worn out actually i don't know if i'll
take a nap but i'll have some coffee i
got a little new little couch back there
i got to put together take a nap on that
thing
well i can't now because i haven't put
it together yet but yeah
uh but yeah so
uh we'll be back tomorrow evening at 5
p.m uh doing our show about sid and
nancy so hopefully you guys can make it
and uh thanks for dropping by today
thanks for your super chats and we'll
see you guys tomorrow